انا هنا في ضاحيه انيار عند مشارثه باريس
وهناك طبعا استعدادات من قبل مشجعي
المنتخب المغربي الذي يعتبر انصاره ان
مباراه اليوم ستكون حاسمه ايضا وان خساره
المنتخب المغربي الاربعاء الماضي في
مواجهه منتخب فرنسا لم يطوي صفحه المشاركه
المغربيه في هذا المونديال لان الفوز في
مواجهه منتخب كرواتيا اليوم سيضع المنتخب
المغربي في المرتبه الثالثه في المونديال
يقول مشجعوا المنتخب المغربي انك كرواتيا
ليست فريقا سهلا فهي وصلت الى النهائيات
كاس العالم وتواجهت عام 2018 في روسيا مع
المنتخب الفرنسي هزم المنتخب الكرواتي
امام منتخب فرنسا عام 2018 باربعه اهداف
لفرنسا مقابل هدفين لكرواتيا لكن كرواتيا
وصلت الى النهائيات في المونديال الماضي
والفوز عليها اليوم سيكون انجازا مهما معي
احد مشجعين المنتخب المغربي الذي وصل الى
هذه الساحه في انيار ومعه العلم المغربي
صباح اليوم صباح الخير عبد الله سلام
عليكم صباح الخير حقيقه المنافسه المنافسه
ستستمر ما احبش هنا لانه هو دين وجهه فريق
اللي هو ماشي بسيط كما قلت اخره في 2018
كان همم في النهائي مع فرنسا
ونتمنى ان شاء الله المنتخب المغربي يزيد
يعيشنا هذا
الاحساس وكان ظن باللي يعني كره القدم هي
اول الحدث اللي همم
الجميع همم
وخصوصا المغرب ونتمنى لهم ان شاء الله همم
ههه احد سعيد وبعدين نكون في المرتبه
الثالثه الثالثه اللي ماشي هي حاجه سهله
يعني هل تعتقد انه كما قال وليد راجراجي
مدرب المنتخب المغربي سيعود المنتخب الى
المغرب مرفوع الراس وفوزه اذا حصل في
مواجهه كرواتيا اليوم سيكون جائزه ارضيه
له تعويضا عن الخساره امام فرنسا همم
بالضبط لانه مركز الثالثه اول مره هذه
يكون فريق عربي
وافريقي ومسلم الذي يصل لها الدرجه شكرا
لك عبد الله هذا بعض من الصوره هنا طبعا
في هذا الحي هنا في الضاحيه انيار الناس
متحمسون
ورغم درجه حراره التدنت الى ما تحت الصفر
فان الناس يستعدون هنا المشجعون يستعدون
ليوم طويل استعدادا لمواكبه مباراه فرنسا
وعفوا لمباراه كرواتيا والمغرب الثلاثه
عشر الفا شرطيا عبر فرنسا
سيواكبون اليوم ما بعد انتهاء مباراه
المغرب وكرواتيا هناك مخاوف من حدوث
اضطرابات مخاوف تتسبب بها مجموعات اقلويه
ليست مرتبطه بالضروره بهذا المنتخب او ذاك
وزير الداخليه طلب تكثيف المراقبه
لمجموعات من اليمين الفرنسي المتطرف
نشاطات يوم الاربعاء الماضي بعد انتهاء
مباراه المغرب فرنسا في بعض المدن مثل نيس
ومونبرديو
سبورت واوقف في باريس 40 شخصا من اليمين
المتطرف كانوا يستعدون للوصول الى جده بعد
انتهاء مباراه المغرب فرنسا كما وقف في
مدينه اليوم 8/12
متطرف كان يستعدون لاثاره اضطرابات كما
قالت مصادر امنيه فاطمه